hello and welcome to the car Kut Channel
well in today's video we're going to be
talking about everything you need to
know about Toyota keys from the smart
key to the mechanical key to diagnosis
to how they work to everything you need
to know there are mainly two types of
keys for Toyotas there is the smart key
and then there is the mechanical key or
also called um internally as a joke the
dumb key before we get started if you're
new to the channel welcome consider
subscribing to the channel check out
some of my other videos if you are AET
return subscriber well thank you so much
for watching another one of my videos
and without further Ado let's get right
into
it starting with the mechanical key or
the key that you turn to start there are
mainly two kinds of those there is the
one that has is called a chip key or a
non-chip key the one with a chip is an
immobilizer the one with without a chip
without an immobilizer so basically if
you have a non-chip key you can go to
your local hardware store cut a metal
key and start the car off you go the
chip key I want you to see the chip and
understand how you can recognize what's
what well the first indication on the
car is if you have a security light
that's the first indication if you don't
have it you don't have a chip key if you
have a security light you do the other
thing is on the key itself on the tip of
the blade there's usually a DOT a letter
some kind of identification for the chip
the ones that do not have a chip will
not have any markings now it could have
a a key like has a remote like this or
it could be just a plain key it doesn't
matter that you're still going to have a
chip and speaking of the chip this is
how the chip looks like here's where
it's located on inside the key inside
the case of the key you drop that out of
it it's done it won't start the car
anymore and then within those all of
these types there are two important
types that you need to know about there
is a master key and there is there's a
valet key a few ways to distinguish
which is which but the main thing I want
you to know is the blade shape this is a
master key watch the blade shape at the
end especially at the tip of the
key and here's a valet key these both
will start the same car but they are
different and the valet key will start
the car but not open the glove box we
not open the trunk you know it's just
used for valet but the important thing
for our purposes here the master key is
a key you can program off of the valet
key you cannot more on that when we talk
toward the end of the video on how you
program these and what happens if you
lose all the keys having said that about
the mechanical Keys the heavy emphasis
of this video is going to be on the
smart key which I see no information on
the internet that is clear and precise
on on so let's dig right into
it so the smart keys or the keyless
start or whatever you want to call it
smart key is official word let's talk
about the consumer side what they do in
a very brief fashion you come to the
door you put the key in your pocket you
touch the door the door opens you open
the door get in put your foot on the
brake press the start button voila car
starts when you're done you press the
button again car shuts off you get out
of the car you touch the little nibbles
on the door or you push a button if you
have an older one and the car locks
itself and life is good but that's not
why you're watching this video let's
talk about actually what happens behind
the scenes how are these Keys
communicating what are their Generations
what's what starting
with so there are small little receivers
all across the car in strategic
locations here's how that looks like
they're called oscillators and all they
do is they communicate with the key as
you approach they're always sending this
signal that the key picks up and once
the key picks it up they start
communicating the main thing they will
communicate is two things first one is
it's called the key ID this is a
permanent code that is stored in every
key and that permanent code is
registered in the car so so that's going
to be the first thing that gets sent and
the second thing that's going to get
sent is called a vehicle ID now that
vehicle ID is unique to every car every
car will have an ID and that ID gets
printed on the key so it's going to send
it okay maybe we have the same key ID
for whatever reason but what about the
vehicle ID this key is not registered to
this car so it needs those two numbers
to match perfectly now there are
different styles and different
configurations of computers but here's
what happens when when the oscillator
gets these two codes the oscillator is
just a receiver he's the mailman he
doesn't make decisions he just get takes
things from A to B the oscillator is
going to send these two codes to a main
muscle of the operation almost it's
called the certification ECU that's
lingo for probably some translation from
Japanese but that's what it's called
it's basically a computer that computer
is going to take these codes and it's
going to communicate with a guy called
the ID box the ID box is a very secure
place where all the codes are stored and
usually in cars equipped with it some
models will have it combined with
another computer but the models that
have it it'll be buried right behind the
HVAC unit between basically all the way
behind the dash you have to tear the
whole car apart just to replace it or
get to it for security of course now
once it communicates the codes to that
computer it's going to ask it hey buddy
do you like these numbers do you see
them in your list you look in their list
yep I got that key registered is it
saying the right vehicle ID yes cool I
like that I like this key we have entry
the ID Box gives authorization to open
the door that goes back to the
certification ECU certification ECU yep
picks up the phone calls the body
computer and the body computer that
controls the locks and the doors tells
them we got to go ahead to open the
doors and Flash the flashers
voila door is open now when you go to
start the car things are different
remember I told you there are placed in
strategic locations these oscillators
there's one by the door there's one
inside in the back all across so the
computer would have an ability to know
not only if this is a right key but
where is it located in the car cuz you
do not want to start the car when the
key is outside near the car you only
want to start the car when the key is
inside by the driver's area and that's
how it's able to tell from these
different locations where is it picking
up the key closest and strongest signal
is what's priority that means that's
where the key is now once the you're
inside you put your foot on the brake
pedal and you hit that start button
here's what actually happens behind the
the scenes the certification computer
through the oscillator is going to get
the two codes we like that codes go to
the ID box they do the same dance but
this time when the certification issue
says we're all good to go it's going to
call two of its best buddies is going to
call the engine computer pick up the
phone call the engine computer tell them
we have a request to start that is
approved the immobilizer the engine
immobilizer has been unset or it has
been unlocked because we have an
authenticated ID code and vehicle code
this key is good we're good to start and
the other thing is going to do and if
you notice in these smart key cars the
steering wheel locks usually in a
mechanical key you put the key turn it
and the key and the steering wheel
unlocks but in a smart key you don't
have that so it actually has a computer
and a little motor that locks the
steering well that's the other computer
that's going to get a call from the
certification ECU hey man we got a key
unlock the steering wheel life is good
car is going to start everything is good
but it doesn't end there because this is
where Toyota takes security a little bit
to the next level because if you were
right next to your car and you started
it and then the key left or they were
hacking into the car trying to steal it
I mean this is we're talking about very
complicated stuff if you have a thief
that is able to bypass all this uh they
could be not interested in your car and
trying to do bigger stuff cuz that's a
lot of highlevel theft here I wish they
were dedicated to better things in life
but nonetheless one last security later
after the car starts after the engine
starts and everything is running within
10 seconds after the car is
starting the computer will send a unique
code that is heavily encrypted to the
certification ECU and to everybody
telling them we are still
good that code is essential because if
this car was hacked stolen whatever the
case may be you you do not initiate that
code from the key you initiate that from
the computer meaning 10 seconds have
passed and we're still good the smart
key still good the code is still good
everything is exactly the same and
everybody has all the computers have
gotten together again and said we're all
good but if it's not it's going to shut
off the engine again and disable
everything some of these cars and they
have a mobilizer problems and especially
when you go putting aftermarket remote
starts that one wire that send that code
it's called the gcode if you are
interested in what it's called that one
wire notorious to break because it's a
tiny communication wire and now the car
starts shuts off within 10 seconds and
nobody knows what's going on it has all
kinds of codes because that one wire is
broken and it cannot send that
confirmation code if you
would let's talk about the generations
of smart Keys briefly so you understand
why they are slightly different and they
how they evolve so the first one is the
initial smart key in any Toyota is the
2004 Prius first generation and the
worst one sorry if you own a 2004 or
second generation Prius actually it's
the whole second generation 04 to9 but
it was ancient and it was horribly
ancient not in a good way not like the
4Runner for example that's a good
ancient it was basically a mechanical
key that had the smart functions kind of
added on top of it so it operated like a
mechanical key but it had this you could
open the door and push the start button
and there was this over complicated
process to program them to do all this
mess and that's why it was gone it was
it was never used in another car other
than the first generation Prius it was
not made by denzo it was made by
somebody else some long name and I'll
put on the screen here that's the
company that made it God bless them they
did a good job but it was a hor system
for lack of better word we're more
interested in the second third fourth
and potentially fifth generation which
is what you see in most of these the
second generation which was great and it
started with the 05 Avalon now the 05
Avalon has a very weird looking key
different than anybody else but it is
actually the same generation that
generation went from 05 all the way to
almost 09 10 depends when the model
changes that generation worked exactly
as we talked that whole same the only
difference between these Generations the
frequencies and some of the computer
orientation was different like some of
them combined the computers some of them
that's only real difference third
generation and fourth generation and I
say that because they're exactly the
same just the frequency changed is the
third generation started from around
2009 2010 and the fourth generation
which is possibly the best so far
started from around 2012 actually it's
debuted on the 2012 Toyota Camry and it
went all the way into a lot of models up
until the ghost fifth generation it's
never really called the fifth generation
because nothing really changed very
minor things Chang but it is actually
what started in the 18
Camry like this 2021 ra for behind me
here's the key and it actually says the
name of the model on it and it
physically looks different than the old
ones however that's the generations of
these keys if you're interested to know
where you fall in this if you don't have
a second generation Prius they all
pretty much work exactly the same and
still today so there is
that so let's talk about a few things
that you might not know about this every
time you shut off your car you open the
door and you leave it open you hear the
annoying
ding that's just the way it is it
reminds you that you need to take your
key out out but if actually you close
the door and open it it locks the
steering wheel and now it don't ding
anymore as they all do that it's very
annoying and if you don't want to close
the door and open it you can just reach
in and press that courtesy switch which
is basically imitates the door closing
and opening and you'll hear a steering
lock engage and life is good the other
thing is you can actually cancel the
smart key functions in the first
generation there was a physical button
in the Prius that cancels the smart
functions and all of them there's a
procedure to cancel it if you cancel the
smart key function you will need to
press the physical button on the REM
mode now that signal goes completely to
a different signal goes to the regular
receiver that has also the tire pressure
monitor in it and that's a completely
different cycle of how you're going to
unlock the doors and when you want to
start the car and this applies the same
if the battery inside of this guy is
dead you're going to hold that key
against it you're going to hold the
Toyota emblem on the key against the
start button and then press it that
actually bypasses cuz this key is able
to transmit things very short range
without a battery that's how they're
designed and there's a receiver in there
it's this over complication to explain
it but we'll keep it simple put this in
front of the emblem of the start button
and life is good another thing is the
battery inside these Keys now most folks
will go years and this battery is still
good some of them every 6 month the
thing is dead and they have to replace
it well here's a tip for you that it was
actually discovered down the road when
the smart key came out so the frequency
that this key transmits on it's
basically the oscillator will send a
small frequency that wakes up the key
and starts the key starts transmitting
the
code if you have another device
computers whatever the case may be that
actually happen to transmit the same
signal this key will start emitting its
signal infinitely
until it's a certain amount of time has
passed then it stops then it gets that
signal again and starts and starts so
that actually kills the battery and and
the way to know if this key is
transmitting is if you look at it it has
a red dot as soon as it starts
transmitting doesn't matter if you could
take this key walk to a similar car
that's not yours it will not unlock it
but I'll actually start flashing that
little red light indicating there's
communication doesn't mean there is
successful communication but there is
communication and that starts draining
the battery now the battery have a fail
safe in it if to protect the battery if
the battery drops below a certain level
it won't flash the light anymore and
eventually it completely dies and shuts
down now you have to hold it against the
start
button now let's get into the uh meats
and potato of this video the programming
part the part that there's not a lot of
information and there there was a lot of
misinformation about so let's start from
the beginning this will apply to both
key types to the mechanical one and the
smart key is a similar process for both
except the first generation key smart
key which happens to be in the 2004 2009
Prius that is completely different let's
start when you have to program a key
this can be done on a dealership but it
also can be done by a good locksmith
they can do that there's no problem with
that all it does is it's going to
require you to have one registered
master key now all smart keys are
Masters there's no such thing but in the
case of the mechanical Keys you need a
master key it cannot be a valet key
because the valet key even with that
security in mind it does not unlock or
do what we need to do so basically
having that key that's already
registered you're going to use that code
to unlock the computers so you get in
them and add a new code for the new key
that's all it is so if you lose one key
most of these cars come with two keys
from the factory some of them three in
the case of the
Mechanicals you need a registered key to
program a new key there's no way around
it that's how it is and that's usually
very cheap at a dealership should not
cost a small fortune if you have a
mechanical key that has a remote the
remote is a separate programming if it
has a separate remote that's also a
separate programming but the smart key
it is a one thing program except the
over o09 Prius that's that's
yeah it's onetime shot you program it
the remote already starts working on the
smart key and everything is done and
then there is another function on the
leadership level don't know if this
locksmith can do that let's say you have
two keys your key was
stolen you know it happens things happen
you already you still have one key you
come to program another key but now
you're worried what if that person that
stole my key is going to come and start
my car and steal my car now so there's a
function to erase Keys you basically
bring us at the dealership all the keys
and we will go in unlock the immobilizer
using your code on the key and then
erase any keys that are not here you're
basically going to scan the keys again
through the start button and tell the
computer these are the only codes I want
to work everything else erase it so you
effectively erase the keys and last but
not least on this section it's very
important that you still have a good a
very good locksmith you can't have an
amateur do this anything to do with the
immobilizer system is Mega complicated
and once thing's locked down it's over
so make sure it's a good locksmith yes
the dealership could charge more but
these keys are very expensive to begin
with and used keys there is a catch with
used Keys we'll talk about this so what
happens if you lose all your keys what
happens then here's the problem if you
don't have a key that works currently to
unlock the immobilizer and all these
computers so you can change things it's
locked it's done you cannot get in so
the only way to get in is through a kind
of a master unlock code called the seed
number that's what toyoto calls it again
a fancy probably translation from
Japanese that seed number is generated
by the by the computer but in order to
decipher that seed number or de decrypt
it you need to go to the Toyota website
online to to you can register this event
you put your name your manager's name
the manager needs to approve it and a
record of this goes to the government
which then will keep track in case this
car was stolen so they know who
programmed the key and they can they
there's a record to track to prevent
thefts because you know what every
technicians have the ability to program
a key and uh not everybody's a good
person so there is a record now you
cannot just program a key steal a car
and have a nice day they're going to
come back after you because they know
you programmed the key
last so once that code is decrypted it
gives you a master unlock code you go
back in the car you enter that seed
number and then the process takes 160
minutes to
unlock the computers and once they are
unlocked they're erased clean and they
are back to their Factory setup where
they are ready to program new keys from
scratch once you are in that state of
everything is fresh and waiting for new
programming similar if you would have
replaced all the
computers
then you can rewrite the vehicle
ID you're probably wondering what am I
talking about used Keys when you buy an
used key off of eBay or Amazon or
whatever that key will get there is an
ability to get it programmed to the car
but it won't work because the vehicle ID
is imprinted in this key now of the
previous car you're trying to run it on
your car it won't work the only time you
can reprogram the vehicle ID inside of
these Keys is when you do basically a l
all keys operation
now this becomes kind of
counterproductive if you buy a used key
to save a few bucks then have to go to
the dealership pay a small fortune to uh
just make this key work why don't you
just buy a new key to begin with I don't
know but here's what that could work if
you have a very very very good locksmith
not everybody and be very careful with
this for the following if you have a
very good locksmith they could have the
ability or the software but to kind of
decrypt that code that comes out of the
car but just know that that's actually a
hack and it is not it's a computer hack
and it is not an official or approved
procedure so you're basically going
through a back door to get this to
happen and the reason I want you to have
a very very good locksmith because if
this goes south you could permanently
lock these computers and now no matter
what you you take it their dealership
they'll just tell you yep you need a few
thousand to replace every single
computer involved because they're all on
lock down now so be careful make sure
the locksmith that is doing this knows
what they are doing and have done it
before because if they don't they could
break your car and you'll they'll
disappear into the wind and you're left
with a four times bigger Bill than if
you would have told your car a
dealership to begin with so be
careful and for diagnosis I want to
share with you a few things the key the
biggest thing is you need to look at the
flashing light on the key as you see
here that light is flashing the key is
communicating with the car now is it
sending the right stuff is it working
right that's different story but that's
your first code of diagnosis the key
stops working the first thing you want
to do is walk up to the door of the car
and then see if that light starts
flashing it'll flash once twice whatever
the case may be but that's your first
mode of diagnosis every time you have a
problem with a smart key system you
replace the battery that's an automatic
the other thing and this is some tips
that I will share with you from
experience I cannot tell you how many
cars get tow in the dealership that
won't start after a dead battery with a
smart key because here's something
that's interesting for you when the
battery dies if it dies in the process
of the smart key starting that whole
communication gets jammed and now we
have like an error and that error stays
because the battery died and it never
got cleared
when you bring a car back from a dead
battery you need to turn the key on and
let it be for a couple minutes otherwise
it won't start you press the start
button nothing happens it just all the
lights and the dash come up nothing
happens and that brings so many people
Towing the car in all I do is go in the
go in the car turn the key on wait for a
minute or two after a jumper is on the
battery and starts right up so I'll
share this one with you because it takes
them some time for all these computers
to communicate
and everything you go back to normal and
this system is really trouble-free for
the most part the oscillators they're
very simple they scattered across the
car typically there's one in the
interior close to the driver's seat
that's the one that picks up when the
key is ready to start and life is good
with this system other than the battery
dying all the time or accidents or
wiring damage stuff that are not DIY
you're really not going to have that
many problems with these and one last
thing that makes these Keys stop working
interference other than you know what we
talked about that kills the battery
similar interference could actually
cause them not to work so when you're
smart key all of a sudden you come to
the door and it doesn't want to open and
it doesn't want to start you got to
unlock hit unlock on the key and then go
inside and put the key against the
button every time you got to look at
your environment if it h especially if
it happens intermittent are you do you
happen to have that problem in the same
spot every time that could be
interference and I've seen so many
people get very frustrated every time I
go out of work it don't want to start I
have to put the key and do all that well
does there happen to be a giant
Transformer right next to the car that
is jamming the signal of this key I
don't know so if you have an
intermittent problem try to isolate it
is it happening in the same spot every
single time cuz I bet you that's going
to be the problem cuz we've seen so many
folks that come in the dealership and
say my smart key does not work sometimes
every time I go to X B or Z it don't
want to start well because you might
have interference in that spot so that's
one thing I want to bring to your
attention as
well if you lose one please make another
one if you lose your mechanical key you
always have two with a car when you go
buy one used ask for the second one if
they don't have it request that is
included in the deal you always should
have two keys for these cars if you lose
one go get one don't procrastinate
because you could easily lose the second
one and now you're stuck with this whole
mess it happens all the time sometimes
I've seen people working at a dealership
I've seen people carry all three keys in
one keychain for the same car and I try
them they're they're for the same car
it's like what's the point of having
three keys if you carry them all we're
going to lose them in one shot job
security for me I suppose please don't
do that I I really it pains my heart
every time I see people having to pay a
small fortune to program keys that they
lost it's it things happen in life but
if you're proactive about it and don't
let it happen you won't be in that
situation one last note I would like to
say before we wrap up this video this
all applies to the newer Toyotas the
receding part there are two cases that
I'd like to bring to your attention one
of them is older cars early 2000s into
the '90s
the ones that have IM
mobilizer unfortunately in these models
and namely 98 to 2002 Sienna that's just
that's one example of them you cannot do
the the receding process when you lose
all keys you have to replace the
computers there's no way to go in
through the scan tool and unlock them to
a new state just like the other ones you
can you cannot do that that's not
possible so you lose all keys on these
is going to easily total that car you
have to replace all the computers so be
careful especially if you have older
ones like that the other thing is there
are some of the new models going back to
that we have had some reports of this R
4 behind me with the mechanical key that
you must replace some components because
they are not unlocking and things are
not working so the moral of this story
is don't lose your keys if things
happened that's why you have two keys
you lost one key go and get a second one
immediately as soon as possible it's
very expensive I understand but trust me
when you lose all your keys it's going
to be even more expensive just thought
i' let you know that I hope this video
was helpful and informative I hope you
learned something new if you like it
consider giving a thumbs up if you're
new to the channel thank you for
watching this video this long consider
subscribing to the channel check out
some of my other videos and until the
next next video folks may the Lord bless
you and keep you and you have a
wonderful day